this rush is a [ __ ] fraud well I
finally talked about it hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record we talk about
water have a cookie oh you have cookies
coffee you know how to eat on the show
apparently we're not yeah okay why our
boss said not to but he gets see I'm not
eating I'm chewing for a camera must
spit all out oh cool
watch oh that makes sense I'm just
kidding for the whole eating thing I
mean why don't we just ask the viewers
if they care if we eat or not good
question that would be a nice update
because the reason why we stopped eating
on camera was because you guys said
that's disgusting can you guys stop
eating it's nasty no no no the real
reason is we had a specific cast mate I
was trying to keep it very very it was
difficult because if you're hosting and
you're reporting the news and you're
just like well and then and then this
[ __ ] thing happened then this
happened and then and then put on and
it's like you can't be [ __ ] doing
that as a host yeah it's like and then
someone else can it said freeze and then
saw one of those [ __ ] ninja teens
yeah there's like strawberries and [ __ ]
they actually happen really close though
you guys instituted a ban against
everyone because of the actions of one
person you're like an H away from Hell
bear most people right like if you go on
like Wang Fu's lunch break or whatever
you have like most people they know how
to eat well mannered
that rules also for us cuz if you had me
eating here like a [ __ ] I'm crap
I'm busted open making man noise it's
distracting and disgust same with [ __ ]
what's-her-name we had her on the show
but we try to keep her to stop from
eating but she couldn't stop it was so
funny
oh we all and I would imagine if all of
us went went to town like that yeah
eating like the way we would if no one
was watching her just by ourselves well
how about we just try it but we we did
we did a patreon that whenever we sneak
the food now yeah I'm super down yeah we
did I don't have
he did a mukbang we did the mock bottom
for print Ron yeah there's people in
this room I still eat that way oh [ __ ]
no not like that person about seaweed
Boyer person that was oh man I didn't
know what they were doing
I like when Joey eats no cuz then he
told you exactly what is eating as you
see me and you never see Joe happier of
them when he's eating he's like gotta go
advanced go talk to ice goes like a
seaweed seaweed yesterday have you seen
that kid that was going around it says
what I'm gonna be looking like when I
first eat at a restaurant after this
quarantine it is this packet and he's
[ __ ] I gotta say the video dude but
the way he's acting it out is like it's
the best [ __ ] food he ever ate and
it's just a perfect description but I
didn't I can imagine
I'll share the video and then the
editors can put it right here so you
guys know what I'm talking about
have you guys made something recently
where you're like [ __ ] that's actually
really good almost every day bro
no I'm sad that I can't share with you
guys you said you JJ you said you cooked
lemon juice oh [ __ ] I forgot to bring
the lemons for ya well yeah what do you
mean quickly no in three weeks they're
gonna be roasted again or dead I was
picking lemons that night for you guys
dark with mosquitos all of my yeah with
the hat on
nah but this is my daytime hat when I
met why I'm picking lemons oh yeah feels
like a farmer's during lunch because
there's no traffic and I'm gonna grab
you the lemons no you don't do that it's
close it's actually really fast now dad
it's not a big deal true there's like no
traffic now zero that was Burger King it
took him like 20 minutes here yeah it's
really fast when normally I'd be like 45
yeah everyone's cooking though right
yeah pretty much I don't see your gut is
cooking stuff I don't post it you it's
funny because you posted more wind
quarantine wasn't happening and you
cooked less oh yeah and you cook more
now and you don't post it
like that cuz me too I don't post
anything now and when I feel like I
should even more and now I'm like even
more like yeah we're counterculture like
that for Revlon oh yeah get it oh yeah
we're gonna post now we're not gonna put
everyone's cookie now we're not gonna
that's how I've always been about mr.
Rogers and finally I'm right about you
get waiting this whole I'll be waiting
oh now we're doing a whole article on
him so we can later but I just am so
happy right now counterculture was
because I always loved to be like not
like Miss Rogers that much just cuz I'd
see people's heads explode because they
can't believe that I always there's
always this thought when I watched mr.
Rogers always have this felt like he
can't be that [ __ ] nice exactly you
just can't like it's nice I just think
the message of telling all the kids that
you're all special no matter what I'm
like na nanana there's stuff that come
out where he's he's a rapist or
something no no I wish what is more that
he told a guy you're trying to destroy
everyone's childhood he wants Bill Cosby
to happen everywhere yeah yeah yeah
there are no heroes I want to call your
girls were Oh you can't destroy my hero
my hero my hero was a cartoon was hot
Sonic the Hedgehog oh that's a sick hero
yeah yeah I mean the first trail that
came out at first trailer exactly they
kind of destroyed everyone's childhood
that's true what Jim Carrey yeah murder
Twitter yeah yeah but I didn't watch a
train redesign Sonic all did Jim Carrey
did that interview with the yeah oh yeah
yeah Carrie would be interviewing he was
like hitting on the girl on the
interview it was one line he on the with
one line but yeah he was like with you
tonight or some [ __ ] like if I was
looking at rhythm of how you said it in
the pause and then the smile after the
pause oh it was weird
I loved Jim Carrey all the way up until
that Netflix documentary about him is
any Kaufman I saw haven't seen the movie
nor the documentary it's the most
obnoxious [ __ ] ever and then once he
once he's telling Andy Kaufman he's like
telling the camera he's like yeah and I
gave Andy Kaufman's daughters great gift
she got to hang out with her dead dad
again as I pretended to be Andy
Kaufman's in front of her right I'm like
who the [ __ ] do you think you are man
it's so [ __ ] crazy but I thought he
lost it after before that film
he's like completely went really yeah
off the wall yeah I
all artists lost it before they even got
famous that's what your famous star
allowed to let it come out right but
most people that I meet that are really
artistic they're just already weird
that's true I know but I believes in
this I'm sure it does but I I just I
loved him use my favorite growing up
Illuminati
he was my favorite he's my favorite it's
crazy that all that goodwill just got
scrapped watching that doctor I was like
damn he's kind of usually yeah like if I
made my childhood hero and he's just
straight-up dick to me I probably like
like Pauly Shore that's what I expected
yeah oh my god that's sick probably
expected you're just [ __ ] nuts that's
how you make it I guess yeah that's true
I wonder if anyone might feel that way
about us I hope they didn't Eve met you
and they're like oh Joe's an ass
yeah but he's no cool on video he's not
what he yeah he's not what I expected I
think that's what I want to see they
always tell me that they go wow you're
actually really quiet in real life yeah
do they expect me to be like Rin jobs
like watching porn yeah I'm picking
lemons yeah this is my outlet because I
think like I'm extra wild on news
because in real life I am I'm serious
yes and no I don't know if I'm alone in
this office and Bart's here alone he
could just be sitting here quietly well
like if Joe's just here all here right
behind me I'm like what's going on I
just see him doing kicks in the corner
by himself part does that too I did
quietly quietly you all would be doing
that if nobody was in the office and the
lights were off yeah scares me about job
okay you really are yourself on camera
it's just like slightly heightened just
lately yeah because 2% I'm Wilder that's
what I'm saying I'm wild and then in
real life I'm serious cuz I'm so focused
on business and all the more proper
stuff you know yeah I don't know if it's
a matter of being serious or funny I
think it's just a matter of being wild
and your stuff a wild regardless I mean
you have got new dark
with your ex because you would play
piano at midnight no we never fought
over piano she liked my piano playing we
fought over stupid instrument I'll get
stupid escalated better and I was like
why would why you got to discriminate
between the instruments that's why all
of these are no longer I'm gonna bring
them home by the way
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that's right you were
picking lemons last night in the dark
and nobody could stop you I wouldn't
have done it if I if it wasn't for you
guys I know and and I got stood up
because stupid ass karma Lisa she wanted
to get a bag of lemons and then I was
like I'm gonna be busy common Lisa we're
gonna be filming Jackie news you guys
how about I come down tonight and I was
like fine I was all right fine let me
get my protein shake and pick some
lemons when in the backyard I was like
oh that's right Casey and [ __ ]
everybody else wants lemons Nikki told
me the other day she wants lemons I
better go get lemons started picking
lemons and there was [ __ ] mosquitoes
everywhere and I was like it's night but
I got to do this for my friends it's so
common Lisa never showed up no she's
like last minute she's like oh I got
something came up and my grad a bag of
lemons for you I could have [ __ ] pick
this [ __ ] on Sunday did you say I'm
gonna get all these lemons for my
friends or did you sing it I said it in
my head
seemingly okay and then his body reacted
to it can I can seem outside one lemons
my friends we did the magic of you
knowing that you see my picture you at
home going crazy since you can't
interact with humans
no you're just like me like you running
around in circles in your little living
room pacing what do you do what's your
coping methods for getting a key bug on
my kitties cats yeah
Pacey yeah he's like an animal in a cage
who's stressed out he just pays his back
in Florida it's true I asked Nikki all
I'll be on the phone my mom my my dad or
somebody and I will pace around the
whole [ __ ] houses I'm on the phone I
have to be moving I have so much [ __ ]
energy
yeah yeah I've been going on walks and
stuff hell yeah yeah yeah that's that's
been great and the main thing you got a
treadmill which has been okay yeah
where'd you guys put it we put it in
like that
red room that we have next to the
kitchen yeah thank [ __ ] for that thing
that's like your hamster wheel yeah
exactly I think you're writing room
right or not no no my office narrator oh
isn't it in between tree yeah so you
just been going on that thing going on
that thing which is great but but mostly
for me it's just talking to people has
been has been great like being able to
do live shows like with me and Joe and
then hopefully we'll get you guys on our
tail I'll be fine you know what's
surprising so my dad is like like
immigrant mindset so I thought he'd be
one of the guys cuz I've already
verbally hear him say like he thought
like Coronas like some [ __ ] [ __ ] or
whatever right so I didn't think he was
gonna properly quarantine or anything
like that and I kept trying to tell my
dad like hey if you don't have groceries
I'll bring it to you like you shouldn't
do in a grocery store like all the time
and all that and he would just tell me
to shut up pretty much but the other day
the other day he came over and this is
what surprised me he came over and he
rang the doorbell when I rang the
doorbell I already see him take two
steps back and then you can hear it I
could go grandpa
cuz he misses him so as soon as Tiger
comes out my dad goes oh [ __ ] this was
maintaining the six feet I my hey Dad
you want to come in he's like no I'm
like this is really weird he takes you
seriously man he does do the newspaper
finally got to him I think so
and then the only reason why he came to
he's so [ __ ] bored is so he found out
our pool got done and he knows Tyco
likes to crawl through the doggie door
so he came just to live just to let me
know hey be careful cuz if you're not
paying attention tiger might go through
the doggie door and then drown and I'm
alright cool got it
he just walks back to his car nature
drives off you could have called you for
that yeah he's just so [ __ ] bored he
had to drive 30 minutes to come see me
home next time you know give me a call
no he's all [ __ ] bored but he's at
least like quarantine and like I know he
knows what social distancing is which is
pretty cool how she's like I touching
you [ __ ] got Corona TECA
I feel like the coronavirus thing was
kind of like it's like literally like
one of those stupid songs you hear on
the radio and you hate that song but
then if you listen to it enough you're
like alright sounds not that bad I feel
like a lot of people don't like that not
that bad well in terms of like clothes
on you it grows on you changes your mind
the non-believers kind of become not
believers but they come like it's part
of my life I guess there's a lot of
social pressure now yes yeah it's just
in your face all the time
two months ago nobody had gloves on that
everyone's got gloves and masks yes oh
yeah it's like you said everyone's
getting ready for surgery especially
like hearing people close to you like
one degree difference or something and
like they're dying from it and they're
just like whoa like this is real like
really real mmm-hmm I got more scared oh
that uh family member passed yeah my
grand aunt passed by the way you guys
yeah that sucks
she passed within five days of of
contact yeah and like the most fucked-up
part about it and my opinion like it's
just so avoidable right cuz she didn't
leave her house at all cuz she had a
pre-existing condition and so she lived
with her daughter and her daughter's
husband had a friend that just passed
from coronavirus and so he went to the
funeral to the viewing and he got it
there so they brought it home and so now
everyone in the household is sick and
they have kids and my grand past they
didn't have rules out there like don't
go to gatherings and [ __ ] well people
are just easier yeah they probably just
think of it as like a sick jet
you know like Chinese people in Taiwan
those street lights are just suggestions
so if it's like the red light noise yeah
they're like when like the president
with the president saying things about
like oh it's not that bad
he just retracted it but yeah for Mexico
Mexican yeah but it's recently he just
changed his mind she was telling people
like crona's not a big deal it's
[ __ ] everyone should hug everyone
should kiss it's a human right like you
guys should see your family
and your loved ones like so he was
encouraging the public to do that and
like yeah I mean it's dude it's crazy
too because the is the economy in Mexico
they they really have a tough time
already and so I think did there's like
a little bit of mixing there when it
comes to incentive so I think the
Mexican president was like we got
everything going right right we want to
keep everything going so let's not tell
everyone about it going on
yeah that's Chen Yin people get [ __ ]
over because of that it sucks man
that's what's happening to our states
that rely on tours and stuff like resume
like they don't want to stop business
right yeah like real estate they're just
going you know like I still see like
empty lands being develop with like
bulldozers and stuff and when I see that
happen I'm thinking like I think some
people in their state they're like I'd
rather make money and potentially die
because if I don't have money I'm dead
anyways right so I think there's a lot
of people that are in that mindset
they're like dude please don't stop me
from work because I did I might as well
die yeah that's what governor lieutenant
it open back up yes it was like saying
I'd like to open back up and then he was
saying like there's more important
things than living that was his quote he
saved choices crazy
Society like we gotta keep humanity
going and like you gotta survive and so
for him he was like I like if I have to
work then my life is not as important as
like continuing like to provide for my
family or whatever oh that sounds like
something george w bush would say yeah
[ __ ] yeah very Texan thing Texas is
dyslexic fool me once shame on you fool
me again god damn it you're not gonna
fool me
this is one car that he said it was like
like as long as there's food
on the backs he doesn't know see there
are no heroes some people could have
looked up to Georgia who the [ __ ] would
look up to George but people voted for
him twice true sure you know what's
funny is I heard that that accent is
just made up cuz it's family they're not
Texans Texans they're in Florida no
they're from [ __ ] Maine bro different
Maine their East Coasters yeah the Bush
family is a banking family and an oil
family from the East Coast and if you
listen to his brother like Jeb and all
these other guys Florida right they
don't sound Texan at all
so she's George Bush June maybe spend
more time there did he live there doing
accent he's doing that's true for the
branding of good old Texas voice oh
there's a George Bush blow me again
goddamn it act like we're not from there
how do we know yeah is it authentic yeah
sure I'm from Texas I don't I've never
had an accident I'm not are you doing
over there a little bit like you get a
little twenty that'd be so cool I want
to hear it can you do it
hey y'all feel like a cowboy already
there yeah yeah say it like he's been
saying his whole life yeah yeah yeah I
forgot what it is but sometimes you'll
say certain things around like on it
there's your Texan
oh yeah I say something that you've
never heard of him that the first time
you heard me
oh yeah you say Saint Chuck a ball you
say chunk of all I don't know why do you
say [ __ ] slapping yeah I think yeah
it's prettier chunk do you do that thing
where somebody you say invited somebody
and yet smack the side of the truck then
they leave yeah
growing up by everyone did that like the
truck I mean I thought that was just
like a older generation thing Billy like
you like um you grab your stuff out of
the back electron you closing right yeah
yeah see that's a southern thing
it's a southern thing I didn't I was
just like a do you see my truck for the
check and then a must to do this cuz
like every time I go to the restaurant
here are like hey excuse me can you get
the check or even in France moving do
that too it's like is that a Texas thing
to do that's what I'm asking oh my god I
like it better than like checked like
this cuz you have what some people would
do this oh that's a lot of Chinese pho
yeah I see that
no I just going on can you get the check
are you still doing something though
excuse me how about this kind of got the
check there we go I [ __ ] up cuz when
we me Nikki were traveling I would say
yeah I think we're all set and that
great and then they don't bring you the
check for like 30 minutes or whatever
that's hilarious yeah Nikki's like stop
saying we're all set you have to just
[ __ ] say we leave us alone right
dammit cuz out here I say it all the
time and then they bring me the check
exactly we're all set meaning we're done
ordering so we write the check now where
do you say that at like a place that
doesn't speak English oh for sure I was
singing everywhere I was hanging all
over Indonesia I'm either going to
Google what you just said and that's
what's taking so long
[Laughter]
[Music]